[Musique]
frédéric dard est ce que vous vous
intéressez à la politique en général ou
est-ce que vous êtes tellement absorbé
par vos livres que vous ne vous y
intéressez pas annonce d'abord je
considère qu'à notre époque il est
possible de se désintéresser de la
politique mais est ce que je trouve
regrettable c'est que la politique se
soit transformée justement par l'intérêt
qu'elles provoquent en une espèce de
spectacle
je trouve que la plupart enfin des
hommes politiques se conduisent comme
des espèces de saltimbanques ils avaient
tous trois jours ici à cette table
devant monsieur médéric et ministre
l'agriculture un petit enfant qu'il
avait invité un petit écolier qui la
demandait ce qu'il pensait des hommes
politiques et il a dit que ça pouvait se
comparer aux guignols fait exactement
c'est en vous savez la vérité sort de la
bouche des enfants et je ne peux qu
renchérit parce que certains spectacles
enfin je ne sais pas si vous voulez je
peux vous tenez d'été des noms pour
étayer ma pensée mais j'ai vu récemment
enfin je sais pas les ibères qui est
votre idée qui mérite d'y aller ce que
je dois faire dans ces cas là rim qui
est en face au cab non le norad et non
avenue toute ouïe non mais je veux dire
que que certains certains hommes
politiques qui déjà avait l'air de
clowns avant il avait l'air de zavatta
maintenant leur popov sept autres choses
bien
[Musique]